hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar optimizing the hurdles of
density gradient ultracentrifugation for
optimized gene therapy purification
workflows I'm Kyle Beckman Coulter life
sciences and I'll be moderating today's
live event I'd like to thank lab routes
for presenting today's webinar which is
brought to you by Beckman Coulter life
sciences a global leader and set a few
Gatien and life science instrumentation
probe again I'd like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive I
encourage you to participate by
submitting questions for our speaker at
any time to do so simply type in the ask
a question box and click send will
answer many questions as we can at the
end of this presentation if you have
trouble see nor hear in the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
to report a problem click on the ask a
question box located at the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational so it offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education education credits
tab located at the top right at the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain these credits for
great pleasure I now present today's
speaker my friend and colleague roster
heel of Beckman Coulter life sciences
Ross has extensive extensive experience
in microfluidic applications paired with
production purification and
characterization of various bio
materials including viral and non-viral
vectors ross has extensive experience in
optimizing density gradient
ultracentrifugation workflows he's
currently a senior application scientist
and Beckman with a focus on expanding
and developing centrifugation
applications for Ross's complete bio
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen Ross please go ahead
and begin your presentation
you
Kyle for that great introduction and
hello everyone today's webinar we are
going to cover as Kyle mentioned looking
at some of the hurdles perceived in
density gradient ultracentrifugation and
we'll go through some examples of how
these a dented gradient applications
apply in gene therapy purification
workflows and give an introduction to
density gradients as a whole so we have
a few just quick legal a slide to go
through and so first addressing the
perceptions about density gradients some
of those being shown here on the slide
one being that densa gradients are too
complex and they're not worth the time
invested to learn or implement another
being that the technique is old and it's
outdated no longer relevant and that
densa grains require super long runtimes
and and don't fit in the process because
of the their duration and finally that
they're only applicable for small-scale
research applications and the focus of
this webinar is going to be to address
these concerns that some people may have
and try to show some examples to dispel
these common perceptions so what we're
going to cover in this webinar then is
an introduction to integrate as a whole
what they are how they're used in what
some of the separation capabilities are
we'll go through examples of how to go
through setting up a density gradient
experiment and what that process is some
of the key considerations and then we'll
have an example of actually putting some
of those steps in action and then
finally we'll go through a few examples
about how density gradients are used in
biotherapeutics purification with the
examples being for a a vs and plasma DNA
so first to get started what is then to
gradient sensor Gatien so in the
simplest form it's conducted in a column
of liquid medium of varying density
which subsequently has varying viscosity
typically and the components in the
sample are separated based on their
physical properties being sized mass and
density along with some others including
shape in the presence of centrifugal
forces and the the means by which the
separation actually occurs is that the
viscosity of the gradient affects the
rate at which the particles moves
through the this liquid column and the
density affects the final position of
the particles and a quick example that a
lot are probably familiar with is PBMC
isolation from blood that's often done
with a cycle gradient as shown here
where the different components of the
blood samples separate based on their
density and from there you can isolate
the component of interest now when
looking at dense agreat ultra
segregation its focuses and operates on
the exact same principles as normal
density grande sensor Gatien with the
key differentiator being that the speeds
and forces exceed 100,000 times the g
so application wise and how these
different techniques are used is the
normal density agent side is used for
larger materials typically because the
forces that need to be applied are much
lower in order to get proper migration
rates and separation of these components
so some of the common examples being
blood components mammalian bacterial and
other types of cells organelles and sub
cellular components but on the ultra
side so it's VG you see it's usually
more applicable for smaller materials so
often under a few hundred nanometers and
common applications include exosome and
other nano particle separations working
with viral vectors and other types of
viruses plasma DNA and many other types
of nucleic acids antibodies and a
variety of other proteins and membrane
fractions including lipoproteins but on
the whole density gradient separations
are used for a wide variety of cells sub
cellular components and different types
of therapeutic materials
so looking at now the separation
capabilities and den screens and what
they can actually do I've pulled a few
examples one being show here which is
looking at viral particles and in a
particular example separating
double-layered
versus triple-layered particles that
only differ by 0.02 grams from L so a
small difference in these particles you
can separate based on another example
being with different types of nucleic
acids so plasmid DNA is a common
application that I mentioned where
you're trying to isolate the super
coiled plasmid versus other DNA and
isoforms and they may differ by point
zero four grams per mil and you can get
even higher resolution that's needed for
stable isotope probing an example here
being a difference of only point zero
zero three six grams per mil between the
label versus unlabeled maleic acid
strands so you can get very high
resolution separations with this
technique and it's also very repeatable
so there's a study that was done with
lipoproteins as another example whereas
only around 2% or less variation within
samples of one rotor and insignificant
variation when looking between different
rotors so it's a very repeatable process
when you're having optimized system in
place and as far as the basis of these
differences go an example being with
viral particles the example before is
that you know they have different layers
and that the ratio of the protein to
nucleic acid cargo is what drives these
differences in the density of material
because proteins has generally lower
density than genetic acids so when
you're changing that ratio you change
the overall density of the particle and
the density gradient separation
techniques can exploit those differences
and facilitate that purification so
overall the density gradients enable
consistent and high purity separations
so in order to relate things back a
little bit to other ultrasound predation
methods so I'll introduce pelleting is
something that most people are very
familiar with
so pelleting separates materials based
on their size and mass also known
collectively as the s value or
sedimentation coefficient are shown at
the bottom of the screen where
increasing size and mass increase the s
value and the higher the s value the
shorter the time it takes to move two
particles from A to B and in the example
shown here to pellet them actually to
the bottom of the tube and the advantage
here is that you get a fast and simple
separation materials that have very
different s values but the the
differences come in to when you have
more similar materials and that's why
density gradients are often used so
there are three main classes of density
gradients types being shown here so rate
zonal equilibrium zonal and ice a picnic
ray zonal is most similar to pelleting
in that the separation basis is again
based on the sedimentation coefficient
and the in this situation you want a
long path length because it's
effectively a race where all the
materials start at the same point as
shown in the picture below and they move
at different rates based on their s
values and the longer the path length is
the longer if the race tracks and you
get more sediment more separation as a
result of that so it's useful for
materials that have very similar s
values on like da loading with the other
two examples they separate on the basis
of density and in in that case use a
different type of gradient materials
which we'll cover a little bit later but
the advantages there are that with
equilibrium zonal it's prepared
typically as a step gradient as shown in
the picture and you can get a one-step
purification and concentration of the
components by density so it's pretty
simple to prepare these gradients and
you can get pretty good separation but
the real advantage of iso technical
agents are that these gradients are
continuous and you can get the highest
possible resolution of separation by
density using I subtract and create
so an example a couple examples that
we'll go through at the end or again as
we mentioned before with viral vectors
in super coiled plasmid DNA so we'll
cover those later and touch on them at
the end of the presentation so in order
to demonstrate the complementarity of
these different types of density
gradients because they separate by
different means we'll walk through this
slide here which shows the density of
materials different types of biomaterial
categories versus their general
sedimentation coefficients and you can
use information like this to help
dictate and drive
what sort of density grant type is
applicable for the material that you're
looking for so as an example say you
want to look at a particular virus that
falls somewhere on the map in this
general location the process you might
go through is starting with your
bioreactor to first harvest your cells
so you might use a high-performance
centrifuge for that step and assuming
that the viral particles of interest are
inside the cells next step would be the
lysis cells again you can use a
high-performance centrifuge to isolate
the components of the lysate and remove
the debris and then from there you might
choose to do a rate zonal type
application so the green bar here shows
the slice that you would obtain from
that rate zonal centrifuge experiment
and it's completely pure you can see
that you might get some other virus
types in there there could be some other
debris that carried along in the process
if you select that slice and it can help
in removing other nucleic acids that are
contaminating which are way on the other
side of the screen because there's a
much different sedimentation coefficient
and then if you follow that up with an
ISO Picnic type density gradient that
can further help remove additional
components to really Zone in on one
specific area of this map and there's
synergies between combining different
types of the centra Gatien techniques
so in terms of being able to get started
using density gradients there's a number
of things to consider especially if you
aren't familiar with density gradients
as as a whole in general and I've
simplified it down to five basic steps
and considerations to go through if
you're looking at implementing this in a
new process and those are shown here and
we'll go through those one by one
so the first being looking at your
starting material and really taking a
closer look at what it is what the
general composition is what the
concentration is of the material of
interest and the volume to to find the
scale so other factors that come in here
in terms of the decision making process
are do you need specific types of
biocontainment you need to maintain
sterility and do you need to remove any
additional components of the of the
mixture before moving on into the
density gradient steps and these
decisions will affect the centrifuge
type that you need so the scale and what
sort of speed range are at whether it's
the high performance or the ultra
centrifuge that we talked about in the
previous slide what type of rotor is
appropriate again for the capacity side
and if there are certain levels of
containment that's needed to scale the
process so if you need multiple
instruments to support the the overall
workflow what types of tubes and sizes
makes sense and then sterilization
method so whether it be for the rotor
the tubes themselves or if you want to
bypass that process and purchase tubes
that are already sterilized
the next thing to look at is the
separation method so this is speaking to
which type of gradient is most
appropriate to isolate the target that
you're going after that's desired from
the contaminant material so picking
picking the gradient type the importance
here is looking at how does the target
material differ from the contaminant so
looking at the properties of the
different types of materials that you're
looking at and then keeping in mind
what's the necessary level of purity
that's expected after this step so if
it's early in the process it maybe is in
a really high-level period it's needed
but if it's very late stage the
expectation is that the level of purity
is much higher so keeping that in mind
and picking appropriately for that
definitely it's important to consider
the effective decisions here are the
rotor so rotors for centrifuges there
are different orientations as the main
way that they're categorized and we'll
go through that a little bit later in
terms of picking the one that's most
appropriate for the sample type as well
as the type of density grading that's
been selected looking at the tube so the
closure type and we'll go through those
a little bit more as well and then the
number of steps in the process so again
speaking to what level P reasoning at
this particular step in mind of what
other purification steps are to follow
downstream so if you're only doing one
centrifuge run or if you plan to do
multiple and combine it with other sorts
of techniques as well
so the third consideration is looking at
the density gradient media itself there
are a wide variety of different types of
media that are used to elicit these
different changes in density and it's
important to consider what is providing
the appropriate range so if you're doing
a density based separation like ISO
picnic you need to make sure that the
gradient material itself
is able to support a wide enough range
and then also if you have functional
particles that need to maintain their
structure or active function different
types of graded materials might interact
different little particles and that also
needs to be maintained the final thing
to keep in mind really is the downstream
workflow as some of the gradient
materials may need to be completely
removed before going on to the next step
while others are more acceptable so just
having a line of sight to the next steps
to come is an additional important
consideration and then the effective
decisions here are the two types that
you might use and its general chemical
compatibility with the material of
interest as well as the density gradient
media and then acceptable run
compositions so to make sure that it
falls within range of what the tubes and
other materials are designed for
so looking a little bit more closely at
some of the different types of density
gradient media a handful of different
categories are shown here with polyhedra
ik alcohol to clean sucrose and glycerol
a couple common types of density
gradient media as well as spike all that
was mentioned before with the PBMC
isolation per call ie Dickson all also
known as Optio prep is shown here in the
high donated material section and then
inorganic salts like cesium chloride and
potassium bromide are common for plasmid
separations and lipoprotein separations
respectively and you can see that
different types of materials are more
commonly used for certain categories of
samples than others where cycle for
example is very common for cells and
organelles large materials not so common
for smaller materials when you get into
nano particle size and proteins while
other things like I Dixon all are pretty
common across the board and they're able
to support a wider variety of workflows
and see them on the other end of the
spectrum isn't very common for cells and
organelles but its more common for the
smaller type materials and the last
thing to look at here is shown on the
left side of this table which shows
self-forming versus layers where some of
these materials function by needing to
be layered before the gradient s steps
which was previously shown but others
are actually self forming once
centrifugal force is applied and you can
exploit some of those differences to
make your work flow a little bit simpler
as is the case for seasoned chloride
usually being treated SSL forming
gradient
so the fourth step in this process is
looking at the experiment design itself
so there's an advantage of density grant
ultra fence creation because it's been
around for a long time this technique is
well-established and as a consequence
there is an extensive publication record
so more often than not if you're looking
to get started with sex with this
technique if you look in the literature
you can often find a protocol that's
using a material that's similar to what
you might be working with or you can
find something that that maybe is close
enough to serve as a starting point and
if you don't find something that's an
exact match you can always consider the
properties of the target of interest
versus the contaminants where if you
know the sedimentation coefficient you
can use that to build out some of these
some of these experiments as well but
it's a lot easier to start with a quick
literature search to get the ball
rolling and the effective decisions here
are finalizing the the needs for the
centrifuge itself the rotor the gradient
specifications and then the run
parameters so the time the speed and the
temperature
so when it comes to picking a rotor the
the three main considerations to keep in
mind are the speed the capacity in the
type so the speed in terms of g-force
that's being applied capacities can be
both the overall volume of the rotor as
well as the number of tubes that it
might accommodate in the type is really
coming down to the orientation or the
path length of the that the sample has
to travel so the three main categories
are shown here at the bottom of the
slide being vertical fixed angle
swinging bucket vertical rotors the tube
is upright in position so it has a short
pass length so for a nice a picnic type
run where you want a short pass length
in order to establish a self-forming
gradient it they're often used in
vertical rotors and you can read some of
those benefits too to that short pass
length whereas fixed angle which is also
commonly used for pelleting you can also
do density gradients in these what if
you have a material that's in the sample
that might be likely to pellet out you
don't have to worry about that in a
fixed angle situation you're also able
to reach high speeds and have relatively
high capacities so some of the common
applications there are using X's ohms
and viral vectors and swinging bucket is
most commonly used for rate zonal type
applications because the tube
orientation changes during segregation
where it swings into an outward position
and you get the longest path length in
this situation so doing separations of
antibodies and in antibiotic conjugates
and X's ohms are most common for this
because you're doing a separation based
on size and not so often density and the
general rule of thumb with with
configuration when it comes to rotor
selection is that if you increase the
speed you decrease the time again
relating to the sedimentation coil
session of the particles and if you
decrease the path length you also
decrease the time so those factors all
come in when you're looking at which
rotor is most appropriate
and then when it comes to tube
selections there's actually quite a
variety of tubes that are available the
main considerations here are the tube
material so largely in terms of chemical
compatibility again with the gradient
media and sample composition itself the
capacity or the volume of the tubes and
the sample containment recovery method
so this comes down to the type of
closure and examples are shown down here
below the blue labels are for the
different tube materials so the most
common ones being polycarbonate ultra
clear and polypropylene with
polypropylene generally having the most
chemical resistance so it's a pretty
common selection but ultra clear
provides a little bit more clarity so if
you really need to see a small quantity
of sample and there a it can be
beneficial for that as well and then
looking at the closure types you can
have a screw cap which is more like a
bottle design on the other end as an
open-top tube which allows for easy
sample recovery and then opti seal and
quick seal tubes are available that can
help maintain sterility and workflow
because the tube itself is actually
completely sealed in the process and
then finally sterile tubes are also
available to an extent and can help
expedite a workflow and make a little
bit easier to get started with a process
so the next part of this is actually
looking at how you're actually going to
assemble these gradients once you know
what you want to do based on a
literature literature search or whatever
method you use to identify the
experiment light to conduct so a few
were shown here
and the step gradient creation usually
is done by a few different methods there
are two general manual methods that you
can use being overlay or underlay shown
here with the overlay approach you will
put the most dense material in first and
then subsequently add the lighter or
less dense layers on top of that to
build up your gradient stepwise with the
underlay methods it's basically the
exact opposite where you actually start
with the least dense material first and
you can use a long needle or cannula to
then subsequently layer in the
increasingly dense materials below it
and in the end you get the same result
which is somewhat it's a matter of
preference under layering it's also
generally more amenable to using tubes
that have a narrower opening select the
quick seal tubes and off to seal tubes
it's often a little bit easier and on
the other hands you can do automated
approaches with automated automated
liquid handlers such as the biomech
that's shown here where you can program
in the desired gradient and and get it
built out for you and a little bit more
of a hands-free method that have some
additional benefits to that
and then for the needs that require
continuous or linear gradients there are
a few different ways to go at making
these with the first being passive
diffusion so in this case you actually
start with step gradient that you
prepare with the one of the methods
above and just using the fusion either
at room temperature refrigeration the
different layers will diffuse over time
and once you have a process that's
optimized you can know that you'll be
getting a continuous layer on the back
end of this using a similar process or
facilitated diffusion that it called
here again you can start with the step
gradient but if you take the tube and
cap it and put it on its side you
increase the surface area between the
different layers of the gradient and
that increased surface area expedites
the diffusion process so you can
basically get a continuous gradient in a
little bit shorter time and then the
third option is using some sort of a
mixing system a two chamber mixer is
showed here where you can actually have
a high density material flow into a
lower density material that's constantly
being mixed so the output density of the
material is constantly changing so this
depiction is sort of a combination of
the underlay method with a mixing system
on the on the front end
and then finally after the the runs been
decided and then you need to get your
sample out and there are a few different
methods that that can be used for the
sampler around the back end of
centrifugation and the simplest one is
shown here first which is just by
patting - especially you have an open
top tube or screw cap type design and
the samples near the top then pipetting
is very amenable to - this sort of
approach the next option which is common
is syringe extraction so there's a
cartoon depiction as well as a picture
of what it actually looks like here
where if you have a sealed tube
especially with the picture shown being
for a quick seal tube you need to
because of the small opening at the top
you need to be able to access the
material often in a different way so the
tubes are puncture bowl from the side so
you can go in there with precision and
be able to isolate just the band of
interest or the material of interest and
not get as much contamination of the of
the impurities that that might be nearby
and then finally you can drain the tube
effectively so instead of doing a
syringe extraction with a needle from
the side in this case you can pierce the
bottom of the tube with a needle there
are also methods that you can use to
actually drain from the top but this is
particularly useful if you don't know
where your sample of interest is or it's
not something that's visible because you
can train the whole tube you can collect
separate fractions as shown here and
then you can collect information in
terms of guiding you towards identifying
which fractions you want to keep which
ones you want to discard because they
have impurities or low concentration or
whatever the reason may be so picking
the recovery method there are a few
different options but depending on the
two types that you selected and where
the the sample resides and the degree of
separation that can help drive towards
making a selection here
finally putting these five steps into
action
in this case it's an example with a
classical AAV type of purification using
density gradients so the first step you
might choose to pre concentrate the cell
lysate first and digest some of the
interfering components and the reason
for this is that if you have a lower
volume of sample going into the den to
grant run it can increase the efficiency
of the whole process and then digesting
the DNA that might be in the solution
reduces viscosity and as we touched on
before viscosity affects the migration
rate so if you have a lower sample
viscosity the particles will move faster
through the solution and you can
actually have a shorter run for the
second step you might choose to do an
equilibrium zonal in a fixed angle rotor
using sterile polypropylene quick seal
tubes and the reason for this is because
then you can maintain sterility with the
with the pre sterile tubes and the
output of the step is that you can
isolate the full AVS from some of the
other contaminants and proteins and then
the third step the type of gradient that
you might select for this then is I'd X
and all which is very common when this
process it allows you to easily
transition into other analysis
techniques such as AC or to go into
further purification if you want to add
on a cesium chloride gradient to really
refine that isolation of the full
particles only and get rid of more of
the the empty and partially full
particles and I Dixon ELLs often
selected it for this application because
it does provide the opportunity for
osmotic balance which helps to maintain
the AAV functionality and without
compromising their integrity and it
doesn't typically in interfere with many
of the downstream sets you might often
use then step four loading the sample is
commonly done at a 1 to 1.5 ratio of the
gradient with it in an optimized an
ultracentrifuge
and the type 70 rotor is a fixed angle
rotor that's very common for this and
the speeds are typically at over 500,000
RC F or G for 80 minutes
in the output here is that you can
concentrate the full AAV particles
separately from the empties and the
partials using a method like this and
then finally on the back end and step 5
doing syringe extraction of the visible
full AAV band and proceeding with the
downstream workflow so again as
mentioned before syringe extraction
allows you to be able to extract the
visible component of interest directly
from the tube and minimize the
contaminant carryover
into the first example that we have
looking at optimizing large-scale ad
purification with density gradient
ultracentrifugation the challenge here
is something that many people in the
field are probably familiar with but
it's to isolate the functional AAV
capsids that have the full genome and
specifically removing the empty and
partially full particles from the sample
and the reason why to use density grant
ultrason predation in this case is
because full and non full a these are
separate on the basis of their density
which we went over before and it's due
to the differences in the protein to
nucleic acid ratios so because a
truncated genome inside the particle
means less total nucleic acid in the
particle it thus has a lower density and
that's the the basis that the the
separation can take advantage of so the
common methods here one example is shown
on a previous slide which is using
simple I did small step gradients in an
equilibrium zonal type of experiment
other methods also include
chromatography including ion exchange
but there are usually numerous steps
required in series to achieve the same
level of purity and it can often be a
very difficult process despite going
through numerous iterations and so the
one opportunity with density gradient
sentence as a whole that that I always
encourage is looking at opportunities
for improvement because it's a long
stained technique there's a lot of
information out there and if you're
following a process that's not specific
to what you're looking at there might be
room for improvement given your own
specific sample type so one thing I'd
like to reference here is the
opportunities for this particular field
in terms of AAV purification with
density gradients the example in the
previous slide is kind of the classical
approach but there's a publication that
that's been out for a while that shows
the opportunity to improve on these
methods by more than seven and a half
fold with
just simple process optimization so
including both optimizing the density
gradient design itself as well as the
run parameters in terms of the speed and
time that's undone and they showed that
there's no difference in the efficacy of
the particles or the productivity so
what they demonstrated here is that you
could get purification from an
equivalent of about ten liters of
starting cell culture in a single twenty
minute density gradient run using the
type 70 router and the overall process
then becomes if you scale that up over
time throughout a eight-hour shift so a
single working day that process that
they came up with is able to process a
hundred and twenty-eight liters of cell
culture using a single instrument so you
can imagine that if you can support a
couple instruments in parallel you can
easily scale out this process to be able
to support increasingly large scales of
of cell culture and viral vector
production in general
second example that we'll cover is with
plasmid DNA the challenge here is to
isolate the complete super coiled
plasmid DNA from other nucleic acids and
proteins and as many people know the
plasmid DNA is the starting material for
a lot of different biotherapeutics
whether it be antibodies of proteins and
enzymes or for viral vectors but getting
a really quality starting material is
important to make sure that the
downstream process is as productive and
effective as possible and so the reason
why these densa grants in this case is
it's well established the seasonal
fluoride method has been around for
decades and many people often find
better transduction efficiency using
this method so the classical approach is
using a seasoned chloride as mentioned
before as the density gradient material
mixed with the city and bromide to help
further exacerbate the differences in
density and do the separation based on
that and there's a picture shown here of
what that sort of separation looks like
and some of the other methods again
include chromatography but as before
with the AV example there are often
numerous sequential steps required to
reach high levels of pyridine and as
before again it's it can be difficult to
reach the the same level of purity as as
many researchers find so again there are
opportunities to improve even upon this
this long-standing method some of the
alternatives include different types of
protocols with different materials so
it's been demonstrated that you can
replace the cesium chloride in a city
and bromide materials with I Dixon all
and Dappy
so there is work being done in terms of
providing maybe some more appropriate
materials that you can use to facilitate
this sort of separations and then
another opportunity is in terms of
changing the process a little bit where
I mentioned before that seasoned
chloride is a cell forming type of
gradient material so the common way that
these experiments are done is making a
homogeneous solution of seasoned
fluoride at a certain density and
upon segregation it will self form based
on the speed that the centrifuge is
running at but this process requires the
greatness of self form and that takes
time and that's the main reason why this
is a longer process then then it
necessarily needs to be in the run times
historically are often 16 hours or more
but it's been shown that if you instead
of starting with a single homogeneous
gradient if you actually pre layer it as
a step gradient the time it takes to
create the equilibrium grain at the end
and reach that status is significantly
reduced and you can take a day long
method down to only a few hours so by
putting a little bit more effort on the
front ends you can significantly reduce
again a very long-standing method it
makes a lot more applicable for
implementation into a workflow
so the final point that we'll talk about
is again in line with the history of
density gradients where it's both
historic so it's been around for for
many many years is largely pioneered by
Bracken and some others in the early
1950s and it really took off in
popularity with the classic meselson and
stahl experiment in 1957 looking at the
replication of DNA so it's been around
for a long time there's been work done
before that but I would argue that it's
still a modern technique as there are
still many leading CRS and CMS globally
offering these services with density
gradient ultracentrifugation implemented
into cGMP workflows so it's still being
done a larger scale and in commercially
available in the publication record
using DG you see still continues to grow
so a number I pulled last week showed
that there were 1,700 publications
according to Google Scholar from 2018 to
where we are right now in 2019 so this
technique still has a lot of traction
and it's still being widely used
and
and finally in summary density grant
ultracentrifugation is a high resolution
purification technique for critical
biotherapeutics and other materials and
it's often chosen for its ability to
provide high quality products in cGMP
environments into again addressing the
few perceptions that I had mentioned
before about density gradients being too
complex outdated really long run times
and only suitable for small scale I
think more modern viewpoint is that you
can simplify the process down to a few
steps it's still being widely used right
now and very modern and emerging
workflows like AAV purification and that
with some optimization you can
significantly improve upon the process
and really reduce run times to increase
both scale and throughput
and I've got included here a few of the
reference that I throughout the
discussion and then finally I'd like to
thank you for your time and for
attending today we if you have interest
in learning more from Beckman Coulter
you can of course visit our website for
lots of content there there's a spin
site section that's new to our website
now which gives some information on some
of the basic techniques and general
concepts about segregation in general
and how we fit into various types of
workflows we have some AC webinars as
well so analytical awesome creation if
you'd be interested in learning about
not just the proper two side of ultra
centrifugation or centra Gatien in
general but how we can actually play a
role in analytical and characterizations
and then there's a detailed density
gradient guide that's very much in line
with today's webinar but provides a lot
more detailed information on examples as
well as how to set up the process
different opportunities and lots of more
literature citations and that's coming
out soon and then finally we'll be at
the biophysical society meeting coming
up in February of 2020 a colleague and I
will be attending and holding a workshop
on those prepara tip and analytical
ultracentrifugation so if you're going
to be at the meeting or if you'd like to
get more information you can meet with
us there at that time so with that again
thank you for your attention and we'll
open it up for questions
Thank You Ross for a great presentation
on overcoming the hurdles of density
gradient ultracentrifugation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of this
webinar as a reminder submit questions
by clicking on the ask a question box
located on the left side of your screen
alright with that we'll get started with
our first question why would I choose to
use density gradients for plasmid prep
when I could just use a kit instead
so that's a good question Kyle so kids
can be useful for screening very small
quantities of plasmids especially in
getting started but the general trend
that I mentioned before is that density
gradients often produce the highest
quality plasmids and even slight
improvements can be impactful on
critical applications like viral vector
production where productivity is already
lower than desirable and there's a lot
of room for improvement there and as a
focal point in in that field so using
density gradients for plasmid prep might
help to further boost the product
outputs
all right thanks Ross the second
question how can exosome isolation be
scaled up for larger production volumes
so this is a really good question as
well and something that we hear about a
lot is as exosomes continue to gain more
interest for large-scale isolation of
something like X's ohms I definitely
look at recommend looking at either
large-scale tube rotors like the type 45
but also the continuous flow
ultracentrifuge offerings that there are
we didn't cover continuous flow rotors
in this webinar though the general
principles are the same and for example
the CF 32 rotor can reach just over a
hundred thousand G which is in the
common space for exosome isolation and
continuous flow rotors
however sample can be continuous pumped
into the spinning rotor and that allows
for the larger materials to be able to
get pushed into the density gradient and
because exosomes from Culture Media are
typically quite low concentrations there
is potential to process large volumes of
the clarified Culture Media in a single
process
all right next question why would a
density gradient give a better
purification that ion exchange
chromatography for AAA B's
the major shortcoming of ion exchange
chromatography is that while the full
and empty particles have a fairly
substantial surface charge difference
the difference of full and partially
full capsid can be very small and
resolving these minut differences can be
very challenging and often requires lots
of protocol optimization upon making any
changes to the system whether it be the
gene of interest or the captain shell
which will have no effect on the surface
charges with density gradients on the
other hand the system reaches a stable
equilibrium as is the case whereas a
picnic gradients that we covered and
because of this equilibrium it's
possible to extract the density range of
interest and further there's little or
no optimization generally needed when
making changes to the AAV design as the
dental granite process is serotype
independent
all right a follow-up question to that
what's the harm in having some partially
full AAA B's present in my final
formulation can't they act as
sacrificial decoy in the body
so this is a good question that comes up
sometimes as well and while some
research has shown that the presence of
non-functional a AVS can act as
sacrificial decoys allowing the full
particles in the mix a better chance of
reaching the target this clearance
phenomenon is still a random process and
the non-functional particles aren't
specifically selected for more than the
full particles so in order to increase
the therapeutic response you could add
either more functional or non-functional
particles however because non-functional
particles obviously cannot and elicits
the desired therapeutic effect they will
only raise the mutagenic potential so I
would strongly recommend working with as
a controlled and purely full particles
as possible to ensure maximum
therapeutic activity at the lowest dose
all right a few more questions
um how do you calculate such low
densities so accurately
so I'll try to read in this question as
best I can
if it's calculating the density of
what's actually coming out so I have the
material the density gradient material
itself refractometers are commonly used
for this whether they use inline or
standalone but yeah typically it's a
refractometer that's used you can also
use an analytical balance if the
question is more directed at calculating
the density of the sample material
itself there are a variety of ways to do
that you can use analytical
ultracentrifugation but one thing to
keep in mind is that the density of the
material in one type of density media
will not necessarily match in something
else and so the example being that if
you had viral particles for example in
sucrose or I diction all they won't
necessarily go to the exact same total
solution media but it's a method because
it balances both the viscous forces as
well and that along with the density
itself
part a few more have come in are there
other alternatives to Athenian bromide
for cesium chloride density gradient
so yes there are alternatives I
mentioned one example in one of the
later slides and these will be available
on demand later that you can review it's
been demonstrated with additional as the
replacement for cesium chloride and then
Dappy instead of Ophidian bromide
there's other work that's been done with
some other type of binding agents I know
I've seen gel green used for some other
types of nucleic acids but there yeah
there are some examples out there that
have been developed already and I think
there are definitely opportunities for
others that can be utilized as well
more questions so can you use this
technique to separate drug loaded
vesicles from empty vesicles and what
kind of gradient material would you
suggest so that's an interesting
question so the short answer is yes
there's definitely potential to help
with that the reason being that the drug
loaded vesicles would likely have a
different density or sedimentation
coefficient that you could exploit so
depending on which of those differences
there is that would drive you towards
picking the right type of density
gradient so for example if the if the
drug is higher in density than the rest
of the particle itself that you probably
could use a ISO Picnic type gradient or
equilibrium zonal if it's a big
difference and then choosing the
appropriate media type to go with that
depends on the the composition of the
drug loaded particle itself but whether
it be I Dixon all-season chloride or
something similar to that would would be
useful
looks like we have one more question
Ross if we have dimerized a B capsids in
our loading sample will they be
localized in the same fraction as
monomeric capsids or will they be in
more dense fraction after centrifugation
is done
so this is a really good question
so it'll depend on how the dimerization
is occurring if there's if the
individual particle density is still
maintained and there aren't any
conformational changes or anything that
would affect the the density of the
particles then you would expect them to
co-localize both the monomer and the
dimer but if there are any changes that
are taking place they would they would
be possible to separate if this is the
the kind of thing that you're trying to
separate that monomer versus dimer the
best approach would be to do a rate zone
run in which case you're looking at the
more the size and the mass of the
particles of the sedimentation
coefficient and you'd be able to do that
sort of separation a lot better with
rate zonal versus and a density based
separation like I subject X
Thank You Ross do you have any final
comments for our audience
things the final comments I have is just
that the density grant
ultracentrifugation technique is really
versatile and can provide a lot of
benefits over some of the other types of
methodologies being chromatography in
some key application areas some of those
applications being a AVS and plasma
purification like I mentioned before
again because the the modality of
separation using this technique is is
largely or can be density based which
not very many other techniques can can
really look at doing separations in that
sort of a method so I think being more
open-minded to to implementing the
density gradient techniques can be
really beneficial as an alternative or
an adjacent purification opportunity
thank you again for taking the time to
discuss density gradient creation I'd
like to also thank lab roots and our
sponsor Beckman Coulter life sciences
before we go I'd like to finally thank
our audience for joining us today and
participating questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information provided in the time of
registration when the webinar recording
is available for replay you will receive
an email from lab roots I encourage you
to share this recording with your
colleagues who may have missed it event
today hope to see you again in our
upcoming webinars until then take care